that's what you get for making so many
badass entertaining movie Thanks so we
know why you're here you got in some
trouble with the police and when I heard
about it I said you know I've known this
guy a long time we agree sometimes he
don't agree but what happened to him
so reminded me of what happened to me
after 9/11 people got upset with what I
said which is okay but then they lied
now about it in my case they lied and
they said well he was denigrating the
military which I never was in your case
what you said and I'll read the
statement you said you were at a
police-brutality rally in New York and
you said when I see murder I can't stand
by half to call them murdered the
murdered and I have to call the
murderers the murderers and the lie is
that you think all cops are murderers
and that's not what the statement says
exactly okay oh go ahead defend yourself
well yeah I mean you know these unions
are becoming out there Patrick Lynch and
everybody you know if they were saying
what I said and they had a problem with
that well then now we're actually
talking about the problem right all
right but they're but they're not
dealing in a fair issue they're they're
caught there saying that I am a cop
hater which is slander because I didn't
say that and they're saying they're
implying that I meant that all cops are
murderers and and I and I wasn't but the
thing that's really sad about is we
actually do need to talk to the cops
about this we never get to the problem
we need to bring this to the table
so you're gonna continue talk yeah
absolutely I'm glad they're not
intimidating you know they can be very
intimidating I mean they can pull you
over yeah well I mean it is kind of
interesting because the thing is a Buick
when I was in my 20s and and and and
broke uh I was a little scared of the
cops all right and all the times I had
warrants out on me for traffic stuff
that I never took care of and everything
jackie Brune oh yeah exactly
no no that that I deal with that in
Jackie bread and I knew what I was
talking about then and you and what
would literally happen I would have like
likes at traffic crap and whatever and
then I'd have like $1500 warrants on me
and I make $10,000 a year so I'd get
stopped and then I'd have to do eight
days in county jail because I couldn't
pay for it to get rid of it um and but
you know since the life you were really
not successful yeah oh yeah oh you know
I I know I never realized how much of a
loser you were you know you might in my
20s I only work for minimum wage and if
I only work for a minimum wage I make
ten thousand I had the same experience I
know you did right so uh it's
interesting there's a it is actually
interesting though to now all of a
sudden I'm looking in my rearview mirror
again I'm seeing the bubble gums again
in a way that I haven't thought about in
20 years right so uh I saw the news last
night there was a police incident in
February in Pennsylvania a female police
officer shot a guy tased and shot a guy
and just was acquitted I thought we
would show this footage I had not seen
it before yesterday so roll this
it's horrible I'm like it's so
disturbing I mean the two shots are here
at the end or bullets before that yeah
the sound you hear our tape you actually
even hearing the guy say he gets shot
and goes what the [ __ ] right and you're
gonna steal that diet yeah but but I I
mean there was no reason to shoot this
person I mean we're not saying all cops
or murderers or it's not worst nut but
this one is this is murder
the guy is on the ground it's very she's
like show me er it's very hard to show
someone your hands when they're being
shot with 150 million watts of taser
volts so then she shoots him what what
danger is this police officer in this
and the hysteria
it says Derry in her voice I don't know
what I understand about the cops they
want us to think they're so brave mm-hmm
okay then they don't always act brave
well you know it's funny that's not
brave I mean we just use a crazy example
all right um okay
in today's world if you got into some
sort of altercation with it you know
we're rubber on the same age you'll
think about back in the 70s or something
if you got into an altercation with a
cop and I'm not encouraging any kind of
altercation with no obviously not we're
doing that all right and you could get
killed doing that right and we and it's
not about that but just use it as a
crazy example say you got into a scuffle
with a cop and you ended up punching
them all right in today's world you just
be shot for that I'm an absolutely shot
if you grab their baton you'd be shot
you would actually be shot for that now
when we were kids in the 70s a we
watched adam-12 there get into fights
all the time and then just take out the
guns and shoot people when you watch the
rookies they got into fights all the
time but if they just actually took out
a gun and shot the hippie we would have
said whoa what's going on
all right but now it actually has become
the new norm right well I don't know if
it's the norm but it but we see cards
like that kind of response are enough
videos where it's not just a few
incidents I can't just be the people who
have cameras it must happen all the time
so again we're not saying all cops do
this or even most but here am I let me
save you or agree with it here are my
issues with cops one do a better job of
weeding out the personality profile who
becomes the bad cop because we all know
that kid in school yeah yeah mm-hmm who
had no friends wasn't popular and
thought hmm if I was the hall monitor
I could lord it over people it's not
that hard to stop that guy from becoming
a cop yeah yeah to be more loyal to
right than to cop
when a cop does a bad thing don't always
be the thin blue line defending the cop
no matter what he does that Serpico and
that was a long time lemon I actually
think you're hitting right on exactly
what the problem is and this is a Hydra
it's a snake with many heads but I
actually think the biggest head that
needs to be chopped off first is this
blue wall idea right the fact that they
would protect their own as opposed to
put themselves at the betterment of
citizenry right and I mean if if it is
just to sit I don't actually don't think
it's an issue of individuals good cops
versus bad cops
I think it's inside of the institution
itself and it is as all problems are if
if they were really really serious about
this they wouldn't close rank on what
I'm obviously talking about which is bad
cops and I'm obviously talking about
specific cases where it is murder as far
as I'm concerned Walter Scott was
murdered do you have to call murder
murder even if it's from the cops there
there's none okay now your plates right
you